Hello, my name is Angela Lomang. Welcome
to 3ABN Today Bible Q&A and I am so glad
you've tuned in. Get your Bibles. If
you're watching, you don't have your
Bible, get your Bible. Even if it's
digital, get it. You're going to be
blessed by this program. Like I am
always blessed. I always learn something
whenever I am hosting Bible Q&A. And
also you are going to learn something
too. Anyway, if thank you for your
prayers and support of this worldwide
ministry and it is much appreciated. God
bless you for doing that. Well, today we
have three
distinguished guests or I should say a
panel. We have here Pastor James Rafidy.
Welcome Pastor James. Hi Angie. Welcome.
Uh I mean thank you for the welcome.
It's good to be here. Looking forward to
our study today. Ah, isn't it always a
blessing?
I know. Always learn something. Always
when it comes to the word of God. Amen.
And next to my husband is Pastor Daniel
Maronei. Welcome, Pastor Maronei. Thank
you so much. It's a privilege to be
here. Appreciate your questions out
there. Thank you for sending them in. We
get to answer them. Amen. Amen. And
right next to you is my husband, Pastor
John Lomchang. Welcome, honey. Now, you
know, I always love being on a program
with you, but I want to thank our Bible
students for sending these questions in
because she always asks us something
that in many cases we we never thought
about before. Yes. Always gives us
reason to learn, isn't it? And my
husband and I, we love to read the word
of God and we do it together. And say,
I'm going show you get you get you into
my home. Okay, real quickly. Say if
we're reading that, I'm bringing my
study Bible today. my remnant study
Bible is highlighted and I do pink or
red for something that's not good. So
whenever we read, say if it's 30 verses,
we'll do probably five each and we'll
comment on it. So just to break it down,
but I'm just so excited about the
program today. And I'm going to ask
Pastor Maronei to open with prayer. All
right. Loving father, thank you that we
have this opportunity and privilege to
open your word together. Thank you for
these questions. Pray for your holy
spirit to help us in these answers and
bless us all. We thank you in Jesus
precious name. Amen. Amen.
Now, maybe you've just joined us and you
have a question that you'd like to
submit to our panel. You can send them
in to our you can email us by going to
bibleqa
at3abn.tv or maybe you want to text your
question. You can text us by going to
6182283975 or maybe you're an
Instagrammer. You can go to Instagram
and go to
3ABN official. All right, let's go
straight to you, Pastor James.
Who is the bride of Christ in Revelation
1-2 and
9-10? Well, that's a great question.
Let's just take a look at the text.
Revelation 21:es 1 and 2 says this. And
I saw a new heaven and a new earth. For
the first heaven and the first earth
were passed away, and there was no more
sea. And I, John, saw the holy city, New
Jerusalem, coming down from God out of
heaven, prepared as a bride adorned for
her husband. In verses 9 and 10, and
there came unto me one of the seven
angels, which had the seven vials full
of the seven last plagues, and talked
with me, saying, Come hither, and I will
show thee the bride, the lamb's wife.
and he carried me away in a spirit to a
great and high mountain and showed me
that great city, the holy Jerusalem
descending out of heaven from God. So
according to these verses, the new
Jerusalem is the bride of Christ. Now,
some might insist that the church is the
bride of Christ as noted through many
Bible passages like 2 Corinthians 11:2
and Jeremiah
3:14. And this is also true. So how do
we reconcile this? You know, sometimes
the Bible gives more than one
designation for a symbol. And when that
happens, we have to allow the context to
determine the
application. For example, in Revelation
5, incense equals the prayers of the
saints. When he had taken the book, the
four beasts and the four and 20 elders
fell down before the lamb, having every
one of them harps and golden vials full
of odors, which are the prayers of the
saints. Revelation 5:8. Yet in
Revelation 8, incense represents the
sacrifice of Christ or his merit.
Another angel came stood at the altar
having a golden sensor that was given
him much incense that he should offer it
with the prayers of the saints upon the
golden altar which is before the throne.
Verse four, and the smoke of the incense
which came with the prayers of the
saints ascended up before God out of the
angel's hand. Revelation 8 3 and 4. And
Ephesians 5:2 confirms this. and walk in
love as Christ has also loved us and
given himself as a an offering and a
sacrifice to God for a sweet smelling
savor. So there's incense representing
Christ sacrifice, Christ's merits that
are mingled with the prayers of the
saints in Revelation 8, whereas incense
is the prayers of the saints in
Revelation 5. So in the same way, God's
church is represented as the bride
throughout the Bible. Yet in Revelation
21, the bride is clearly the new
Jerusalem city. And in a way it includes
the church for all of the redeemed make
up the new Jerusalem city. Each one like
a stone and Jesus himself being the
chief cornerstone according to Ephesians
2:es 19 to 22. Now therefore, you are no
more strangers and foreigners, but
fellow citizens of the saints, and of
the household of God, and are built upon
the foundation of the apostles and
prophets, Jesus Christ himself, being
the chief cornerstone, in whom all the
building fitly framed together, growth
into a holy temple in the Lord, in whom
you also are builded together for a holy
habitation of God through the spirit.
Again, Ephesians
2:19-22. So, I hope that's helpful. That
was very helpful. I just want to be in
the kingdom and I know you do too. I
want to see my Jesus. That's right.
Amen. That's the most important person I
want to see is my Lord. All right. Thank
you for that, Pastor Maronei. This is an
interesting question. Are the people who
have never heard the gospel lost? This
is from Lee in Texas.
Thank you, Lee, for that question. You
know, I used to wonder that same
question actually. So let me read a
couple of texts and then I'll expound on
them. In John 12:32 it says this is
Jesus talking. And I if I be lifted up
from the earth will draw all men unto
me. So it sounds like Jesus is drawing
everybody to himself. Jesus said that he
would draw everyone to himself when he
was crucified. And he's no respector of
persons. When Jesus was speaking to
Nicodemus in John chapter 3 and verse 8,
he said, "The wind bloweth where it
listeth, and thou hearest the sound
thereof, but can't not tell whence it
cometh, and whether it goeth." So is
everyone that is born of the spirit. So
he's saying that we can't see what the
Holy Spirit is doing on the inside of a
person. So we don't know what God is
saying to an individual through his holy
spirit, but it says, "So is everyone
that is born of the spirit." So this is
Jesus's explanation of being born again.
He basically was saying that we can see
and hear the results of the wind but not
the wind
itself. We have Jesus is saying in
Matthew chapter 7 and verse 21, not
everyone that saith unto me, Lord, Lord,
shall enter into the kingdom of heaven,
but he that doeth the will of my father
which is in heaven. So it's not so much
what the person's professing as much as
what they do. And we see that here in
Matthew chap 25 beginning with verse
31. This parable that Jesus shares about
the last days. When the son of man shall
come in his glory and all the holy
angels with him. Then shall he sit upon
the throne of his glory. And before him
shall be gathered all
nations. And he shall separate them one
from another as a shepherd divideth his
sheep from the goats. And he shall set
the sheep on his right hand. but the
goats on his left. Then shall the king
say unto the them on his right hand,
come ye blessed of my father, inherit
the kingdom prepared for you from the
foundation of the world. And this is the
things that these people were doing. He
says, I was hungered and you gave me
meat. I was thirsty and you gave me
drink. I was a stranger and you took me
in. Naked and you clothed me. I was sick
and you visited me. I was in prison and
you came unto me. Then shall the
righteous answer him, saying,"Lord, when
saw we thee and hungered and fed thee,
or thirsty and gave thee drink." So you
can see by the questions these people
that are are called righteous, they
don't know that they were doing these
things to Jesus. And since this story in
Matthew is part of the gospel, it
doesn't sound like they have ever heard
the gospel. And yet these people are
saved. So it sounds like it's more what
you do for Jesus and his Holy Spirit
speaking to all people that Jesus is
drawing all men unto himself so we don't
have to worry about those Jesus loves
everybody and so he's drawing everybody
to himself and that seems like when
they're listening to the Holy Spirit and
doing what he wants them they'll be
saved. That's the key. Listen to the
Holy Spirit. Yeah. Yeah. And we know in
Acts 17:30 and31 says times of ignorance
God winks at but we're not living in
those times are we especially with the
with all the what satellites and 3ABN
and knowledge has increased. So thank
you wonderful. Okay Pastor John this is
a good one. Though I believe here's your
question. Though I believe in the
Sabbath and honor it, can we serve our
prior church when called upon? H
okay. Well, let me be very clear about
this uh question. Uh the issue is not
cleaning or serving or like like the
extended question was like putting tithe
envelopes I guess in the pews. It's a
hard issue. Yeah. Uh that's really what
most of the circumstances are. people
are leaving one place and going to the
other. I'll give you an example and I'll
give you some scriptures. One of the
scriptures that um are very is very
important is Luke
9:62. But Jesus said to him, "No one
having put his hand to the plow and
looking back is fit for the kingdom of
God." The problem with stilling, the
problem with meandering where you left
and not giving full commitment to where
you're headed, your heart is is divided.
Yeah. And we cannot serve God with a
divided heart because sooner or later,
the Bible says you cannot serve two
masters. Sooner or later, you got to let
go of one and fully embrace the other.
We had people here in our church that
left their churches because they found
the doctrines were correct here, but
they like the music there. You know what
happened? They ended up going back
because they kept on going for the music
and they end up going back for the
music. There are those who came and
said, "Your teachings are solidly Bible,
but I missed the excitement and the
emotion, they ended up going back. They
they they they did not the Bible says
because they received now the love of
the truth." Yes. That they might be
saved. So, you got to love the truth
more than I want to just serve. I want
to be there because wherever your
treasure is, there your heart is going
to be also. And so, the message of
Jesus, John 10:16, he says, "Other sheep
I have that are not of this fold." But
he said this, "The themm also I must
bring, and they will hear my voice." And
notice this, there'll be one fold and
one shepherd. In other words, he's not
leaving the other fold active to keep
going back and forth. He intends it to
be one fold, one shepherd. Ephesians,
one Lord, one faith, one baptism, one
God, one father of all. So this
duplicitous service is not what God
accepts. You got to decide as um as um
Elijah said to those on Mount Carmel, if
God be God, then serve him. But if Bale
be God, then serve him. So you got to
make sure that you are in the right
place physically and spiritually. Not
just, well, I love your teachings, but I
want to keep serving in my last church.
You're going to end up tripping back and
forth. We one story I end with before I
give it back to you, honey. Uh we don't
want to draw near to God with our mouth
and honor him with our lips, but our
hearts are far from him. I was studying
with a young lady who started attending
our church, but her former church family
said, "We miss you. We love you. we we
we want you back. And she kept going
back periodically until before you know
it, she put her hand to the plow. Yeah.
And looked back. And you know the
warning in the book of Luke is that very
thing. When the Lord says like Talot's
wife, go forward and don't look back. He
means that don't look back. Uh we had
people that have looked back and they
end up going back. Just before the
children of Israel said to Moses, take
us back to Egypt, they started looking
back at Egypt. M my encouragement, look
forward and follow the Lord. Amen. And
go find a Seventh Day Adventist church.
Speak to the pastor. Yeah, they're
they're actually attending one, but they
keep they keep on attending the other
church. But yeah, but uh speak get
grounded. Stay stay with the truth.
Amen. Okay, Pastor James, here's your
question. Can you explain Hebrews
chapter Hebrews 11:4?
How can a person speak when they're
dead? Isn't this contradictory to
Ecclesiastes 95 and 6? This is from
Anthony in Ohio.
Well, Anthony in Ohio, that is a great
question. Ephesians 11 and verse 4 says,
"By faith, Abel offered unto God a more
excellent sacrifice than Cain, by which
he obtained witness that he was
righteous. God testifying of his gifts
and by it he being dead yet speaketh.
Well, you are correct, Anthony, when you
say that the dead cannot speak.
Ecclesiastes chapter 9:es 5 and 6 say,
"For the living know that they shall
die, but the dead know not anything,
neither have they any more reward, for
the memory of them is forgotten. Also
their love, their hatred, their envy is
now perished. Neither have they any more
a portion forever in anything that is
done under the sun. So the context of
Hebrews 11 explains the meaning here.
Abel is speaking by the testimony of his
experience when he was alive. What Abel
did when he was alive speaks to us
today. We see the same thing for example
in Daniel 12. Daniel was told in Daniel
12:4, "But thou, oh Daniel, shut up the
word, seal the book even till the time
of the end. Many shall run to and fro
and knowledge shall be increased. Those
these were the words that Daniel had was
given of God. The visions and the
message Daniel was given of God. It was
sealed up. There was a certain portion
of Daniel's book that just couldn't be
understtood by him and by many people
for many centuries. And then he was told
in verse 9, "Go thy way, Daniel, for thy
words are sealed up until the time of
the end." Verse 10, "Many shall be
purified and made white and tried. The
wicked shall do wickedly. None of the
wicked shall understand, but the wise
shall understand. Go your way, verse 13,
he was told, uh, until the end be, for
thou shalt rest and shall stand in thy
lot at the end of the days. Now,
certainly, we don't uh uh interpret this
as Daniel being resurrected and standing
up in the end of days. It's referring to
his words. It's referring to the
prophecies of Daniel. It's referring to
the prophetic book of Daniel. It was
sealed up for many centuries and then it
was opened and Daniel as it were spoke
or stood in his lot at the end of the
days. So in the Bible we we are clearly
told the dead rest in the grave until
the resurrection. They don't know
anything. They don't praise the Lord. Uh
yet they we also know that the written
words, the recorded actions and the
memories of the dead, their lives, their
history, even their last will and
testimony speak to the generations that
follow. The whole Bible is filled with
people who are resting in the grave and
yet still speak to us through what they
wrote or through the the testimony of
their lives. So this is how we
understand that Abel spoke even after he
was dead. In fact, his life speaks to us
today even now of his faithfulness to
God. And it is not Abel but also Abraham
and David and Moses and many others
whose words uh live and speak to us
today in the recorded testimony of the
Bible. Thank you, Pastor Raphid. Okay,
our next question, uh, Pastor
Maronei, will you be saved if you die
before being baptized? This is from
Felipe in New York. Well, thank you,
Felipe. You know, we usually go to the
thief on the cross for this one, but
let's pick it up here in uh Luke 23 and
verse 39. We see Jesus hanging on the
cross, and we pick up the scene here.
One of the male factors, thieves, which
were hanged, railed on him, saying, "If
thou be the Christ, save thyself and
us," more than likely sarcastically
saying this. But the other thief comes
in here in verse 40. But the other
answer rebuked him, saying, "Dust not
thou fear God, seeing thou art in the
same condemnation, and we indeed justly,
for we receive the due reward of our
deeds, but this man hath done nothing a
miss." And he said unto Jesus, Lord,
remember me when thou comest in thy
kingdom. And Jesus said unto him, verily
I say unto thee today, thou shalt be
with me in paradise. He died and he
wasn't baptized. Yet Jesus said that he
would be saved. He'd be in heaven with
him. But when we have the other side
here in Acts 2 37-38. So this man wasn't
able to be baptized there.
Uh after Jesus ascended to heaven, the
disciples were in one accord on the day
of Pentecost. And Peter stood up to
preach. We pick this one up in verse 37.
When he had finished preaching, now when
they heard this, they were pricricked in
their heart and said unto Peter and to
the rest of the apostles, "Men and
brethren, what shall we do?" Then Peter
said unto them, "Repent and be baptized,
every one of you, in the name of Jesus
Christ, for the remission of sins, and
you shall receive the gift of the Holy
Ghost." So it sounds like if you have
the opportunity to be baptized after
your conversion experience, you need to
be. But if you're unable to be baptized
and you pass away, then God knows the
heart of the individual. And Jesus's
baptism is credited for this individual.
It represents our death, burial, and
resurrection. Death to our old selfish
ways and resurrection to our new
selfless life in Jesus. It becomes an
example for others too to follow Jesus.
So again, thank you Filipe for that
question. All right. Amen. Thank you.
Okay, Pastor John in Psalms
23:E4 that it says, "Thy rod and thy
staff, they comfort me." What is this
phrase symbolic of? This is from Chad.
Okay. Well, one of the very uh enduring
symbols in scripture is uh the shepherd.
You know, we always say I think the most
repeated prayer is the Lord is my
shepherd. You know, you could go to
almost any place. People that are not
even Christian, the minister would say,
"Repeat after me." And everybody would
say, "The Lord is my shepherd. I shall
not want." They might not know the whole
thing, but they at least know, "The Lord
is my shepherd. I shall not want." Well,
that's the picture that uh David the
Psalmist because David was a shepherd
boy. You find Moses was a shepherd also
in the wilderness for 40 years. And you
find Jesus refers to himself as the
chief shepherd in John chapter 10. So
all shepherds have a staff which is
which is a two-sided instrument. You
have the curved end which is the top and
the bottom end which is blunted and in
many cases it's made of some kind of
blunted metal uh either hardened wood or
in most cases metal. You find here in
the book of Micah uh a phrase towards uh
the very belief that the shepherd is the
leader of his sheep. Mhm. Micah 7:14,
speaking about Jesus to come, shepherd
your people with your staff, the flock
of your heritage, who dwell uh uh
solidarity solitarily in a woodland, in
the midst of Carmel. Let them feed in
Bashan and Gilead as in days of old.
Referring to the work that the Lord will
do when he comes. So why why the two
part to the to the uh shepherd's rod if
I could use that phrase which is what
the Bible uses. Now the top part is
curved and it's often is a long long
staff. The curved part is designed to
delicat delicately keep the sheep in the
fold. If they're straying away, the
shepherd extends that kind of leads the
sheep back. He doesn't yank it back to
choke them. But if he sees a wolf
coming, he uses the other end as a as an
instrument of instrument of defense.
That's why David says, "Your rod and
your staff, they comfort me." I'm
comfortable that if I start straying
away, you're going to lead me back. But
if I'm in danger, you are going to
defend me for your rod and your staff,
they comfort me. You know, when you have
somebody that cares about your uh
direction in life, like the shepherd
does, he wants to make sure he keeps the
sheep in the fold. And if for whatever
reason they stray away from the foe,
he'll go find them and lovingly hold
them to his bosom and bring them back.
And this is a fitting example of Jesus.
Revelation 12 and verse 5 speaking about
Jesus. She bore a male child who was to
rule all nations with a rod of iron.
Yes. And her child was caught up to God
and to his throne. So that's the Lord
Jesus our savior. He is our shepherd.
He's your shepherd. Anyone who accepts
him, he's our shepherd. And truly his
rod and staff are what we need to make
it to the kingdom. Amen. Thank you honey
for that answer. All right, let's go to
the next question. Pastor
Raffidy, is the concept of obedience to
God's law one of the conditions by which
our salvation has to take
place? And can we accomplish sinlessness
of character in this lifetime?
Great question. Yes, obedience to God's
law is one of the conditions by which
our salvation takes place. The problem
is that fallen humanity is not able to
perfectly obey God's law. And therefore,
we find ourselves perfectly lost.
However, because perfect obedience to
God's law is the requirement for heaven,
God stepped into our humanity in the
person of Jesus Christ, working out for
us in his life the perfect obedience
necessary for salvation. This entire
dilemma and its heavenly cure is
outlined for us in the following Bible
verses beginning in Romans
7:12. Wherefore the law is holy and the
commandment is holy and just and good.
Was then that which is good made death
unto me? God forbid, but sin that it
might appear sin, working death in me by
that which is good, that sin by the
commandment might become exceedingly
sinful. For we know that the law is
spiritual, but I am carnal, sold under
sin. Verse 15, for that which I do allow
not, that which I do, I allow not. For
what I would, that I do not, but what I
hate, that I do. Can you relate? If then
I do that which I would not, I consent
unto the law that it is good, now then
it is no more I that do it, but sin that
dwells in me. For I know, verse 18, that
in me that is in my flesh dwells no good
thing. For the will is present with me.
But how to perform that which is good, I
find not. For the good that I would, I
do not. But the evil which I would not,
that I do. Now if I do that which I
would not, it is no more I that do it,
but sin that dwells in me. I find then a
law that when I would do good, evil is
present with me. For I delight in the
law of God after the inward man. But I
see another law in my members, warning
against the law of my mind and bringing
me into subjection into captivity to the
law of sin which is in my members. Oh
wretched man that I am. Who shall
deliver me from the body of this death?
Verse 25, Romans 7. I thank God through
Jesus Christ our Lord. So then with the
mind I myself serve the law of God, but
with the flesh, the law of sin. It
doesn't end there. Romans 8:1, there is
therefore no con now no condemnation to
them which are in Christ Jesus who walk
not after the flesh but after the
spirit. For the law of the spirit of
life in Christ Jesus has made me free
from the law of sin and death. For what
the law could not do, and that it was
weak through the flesh, God sending his
own son in the likeness of sinful flesh,
and for sin, condemn sin in the flesh,
that the righteousness of the law might
be fulfilled in us who walk not after
the flesh, but after the spirit. For
they that are of the flesh do mind the
things of the flesh, but they that are
of the spirit, the things of the spirit.
So, we're not saved by our obedience to
God's law. That is old covenant. And it
proved to be impossible for humans,
fallen humans, can never merit their
salvation by keeping God's law. We are
saved by Christ's perfect obedience to
God's law. Because perfect obedience is
one of the conditions by which our
salvation takes place. And Christ was
the only human who ever was and ever has
been perfectly obedient to God's law
without ever sinning in action, in word,
in thought, in motive. Now, regarding
the sinless character, I certainly hope
that I'm not stuck being impatient and
unkind and envious and angry and
generally uncristlike until Jesus comes.
Yet, I certainly do not think that I
will ever perceive myself as without
sin. 1 John 1:8 says, "If we say we have
no sin, we deceive ourselves and the
truth is not in us." Verse 9, "If we
confess our sins, he is faithful and
just to forgive us our sins and to
cleanse us from all unrighteousness."
Verse 10. If we say we have not sinned,
we make him a liar and his word is not
in us. I sure hope this was helpful and
it gets a good thumbs up from everyone
who's listening.
All right, good answer. As Philippians
4:13 says, I can do all things through
Christ. What does he do? Strengthens me.
Amen. And that's very encouraging.
Okay, Pastor Maronei, this is a little
lengthy question, so here we go.
Can you explain some of the communion
practices of the Adventist Church? Why
do they celebrate the Lord's Supper with
small pieces of bread and a small glass
of grape
juice? Why does the bread have to be
burned
afterward? Why may the bread and juice
only be distributed by special persons?
Why do pastors claim that if you don't
take part, you will be
lost? Why are children excluded from a
dinner? This is from Bridgetette in
Austria.
Well, thank you Bridget for that sincere
question.
So let me read what Paul says here in 1
Corinthians chap 11 and let's begin with
verse 23 and then continue onward and
I'll share stuff. For I have received of
the Lord that which I delivered unto you
that the Lord Jesus the same night in
which he was betrayed took bread. And
when he had given thanks, he broke it
and said, "Take, eat. This is my body
which is broken for you. This do in
remembrance of me." And after the same
manner also he took the cup when he had
sucked, saying, "This cup is a new
testament or covenant in my blood. This
do ye as often as you drink it in
remembrance of
me. For as often as you eat this bread
and drink this cup, you do show the
Lord's death till he come." By the way,
this service was to take the place of
the Passover, which reminded the
Israelites of God's deliverance from
them from Egypt, slavery in Egypt. and
it pointed forward to Jesus's sacrifice
on the cross for our deliverance from
sin. Let's jump back in with verse 27.
Wherefore, whosoever shall eat this
bread and drink this cup of the Lord
unworthily shall be guilty of the body
and blood of the Lord. But let a man
examine himself, and so let him eat of
that bread, and drink of that cup. Mhm.
For he that eateth and drinkkeeth
unworthily eateth and drinkkeeth
damnation to himself, not discerning the
Lord's body. So the Greek word for
unworthily is an axe eos, which could
also be translated irreverently.
So this might answer some of your
questions regarding the protocol or
procedure or the reverence that we uh
show in this service.
to show reverence or respect or honor,
maybe even an awe in regards to service
being a sacred service. Kind of like
going to a funeral. You know, there's
people you show respect or honor by
following an organized, thoughtout,
planned service. And these individual
little cups and wafers more than likely
were introduced for
sanitary and expeditious purposes
because when Jesus gave it, he just took
his cup and gave it and they kept
passing it around and then the bread and
so forth. So, but not including little
children till they were are baptized
keeps it special and gives them
something to look forward to. Kind of
like the bar mitzvah in the Jewish
tradition in regard to pastors saying
that someone will be lost because they
don't partake of the communion service
could come from verses 28 and 29 where
it commands let every man examine
himself or search his heart. Like on the
day of atonement or Yam Kapor, the
Israelites were to afflict their souls,
meaning to examine themselves to see if
their lives were being lived for self or
for God. The Bible says, "If they didn't
do that, they were cut off from the
congregation." That's in Leviticus
23:9. For whatsoever soul that shall not
be afflicted in that same day, he shall
be cut off from among his people. So I
believe we could think we are doing okay
in our walk with Jesus when we compare
ourselves with others rather than
searching our hearts and comparing it to
Jesus's heart and his selfless nature.
So this sacred service it gives us the
opportunity to do this. I hope that's a
help to you Bridget. Thanks for the
question. Amen. That's right. Communion
is very special and in the Adventist
church we do that I think is what four
times a year? Four times a year. Yes.
And it's very reverent because we are
what uplifting Jesus through his death,
burial, and
baptism. And it's not alcohol. We don't
use alcohol because alcohol is the it
represents sin and yeast. Okay. So
anyway, that's just a little nugget
here. Thank you. Well said.
Okay, Pastor John, can you explain
Colossians 2 verse 16? Yes, thank you
for the question. This is often a verse
that's cited for one primary reason, not
for the entire verse, but for the last
word, Sabbaths. Let me read it for you.
So, let no one judge you in food or in
drink or regarding a festival or a new
moon or Sabbaths. This is a very common
passage quoted by pastors that want to
get rid of the Sabbath. They think that
somehow the Apostle Paul had the
authority to eliminate the Sabbath that
was established at the end of creation
week. Now consider this. How many days
are there in a week? Seven days in a
week. How many days the Lord used to
create the world? Six days. Now in six
days the Lord made the heavens and the
earth and the sea and all that is in
them. Exodus 20 says, "And on the
seventh day, he rested from all his
works." Now get this. Genesis chapter 2
talks about what he did with that last
day. He rested. He blessed it. He
sanctified that day. And Exodus chapter
20 makes it very clear what the purpose
of that. Remember the Sabbath to keep it
holy. And he points right to creation.
For in six days the Lord made the
heavens and the earth. He calls he says
Exodus 20:8-10, the seventh day is the
Sabbath of the Lord your God. So now
there's a quandry here. Many people
honor Sunday the first day of the week
and there is no scriptural support
giving any soity to that day any
blessedness to that day is one of the
work days of the week but tradition has
tried to
supplant and in a great sense in a
secular way and in many Christians minds
Sunday is the holy day of the week but
there's no scriptural support for that
there are 12 verses in the New Testament
that brings in the first day eight of
those verses refer to the resurrection
of Jesus Christ. And then you have the
the last four refer to various other
incidences like breaking bread on the
first day of the week in Acts 20:7. Uh
collecting for those who were in
jeopardy in Jerusalem. Uh 1 Corinthians
chapter 16 verse1. And then you have the
meeting of Jesus with the disciples. He
met with them on the first day of the
week. It was not a service. They were
hiding for fear of the Jews. That's in
John chapter 20. So you find these three
examples. And the very last one was when
Paul was preaching and uh getting ready
to go on a trip around Asia Minor and he
preached until midnight and that was not
a change of the day. So there's no
scriptural support for a new day of
worship. So this particular passage is
referring to ceremonial Sabbaths. You
find in Galatians now there were the ten
commandments that were in place. That's
why from the very beginning when Cain
killed Abel, he could not be guilty of
murder unless there was a thou shalt not
kill law. It wasn't written for 1500
years. There was no written record, but
there was a violation of the character
of the law of God there. So you find
also Galatians 3:19 talks about this law
continued to be violated. So then a
ceremonial law was added. Galatians
3:19, what purpose then does the law
serve? This is the ceremonial. It was
added because of transgression, because
of continual violation of the ten
commandments. How long till the seed
should come to whom the promise was
made? And it was appointed through
angels by the hand of the mediator. Now,
if you want to find out all the
ceremonial Sabbaths referred to here, go
to Leviticus chapter 23. You find a
first day, an eighth day, uh a one that
happens every uh seven weeks. You have
one that happens every seven years. and
um but not the seventh day Sabbath that
was created before sin entered the
world. So when you read this, this is
not any
indication that God's 7th day Sabbath,
the blessing of the last day of the week
needed to be eliminated. It is a it is a
capstone of creation, a reminder.
Ezekiel 202 and 20 is a sign between God
and his people. And then Jesus said in
Mark 27 and 28, "The Sabbath was made
for man and not man for the Sabbath."
When you honor that, you acknowledge God
and Jesus as your creator and your
redeemer. And it's not eliminated. Amen.
And it is one of the ten commandments
talking about. Matter of fact, very
important point. A lot of people take
the Sabbath out of the commandments and
say, "Okay, we keep the commandments,
but what about the Sabbath?" There is no
what about. It's one of the 10. You
cannot take it out. But so many clergy
today have made it some kind of a side
issue. Yeah. And have not allowed the
ten commandments to stay intact. Wow.
Yeah. I am so glad that you are learning
today. This is just wonderful. I hope
you were blessed because I am. Okay.
Pastor Raphid, thank you honey for that.
We measure time by sunset to sunset as
the days, lunar cycles as the months,
and four seasons around the sun as the
years. How will we measure time in
heaven? This is from Thirsten in
Tennessee.
Thank you for your question, Thirsten in
Tennessee. Let's take a look at a couple
of Bible texts that speak about the new
heavens and the new earth and see if we
can learn from them what time will be
measured by in that time of the new
heavens and the new earth. The first one
we want to look at is found in Isaiah
chapter 63. Excuse me. Isaiah chapter 66
and verse 23. Isaiah 66 and verse 23
says this. And it shall come to pass
that from one new moon to another and
from one Sabbath to another shall all
flesh come to worship before me, says
the Lord. So every Sabbath and every new
moon. This suggests that time will be
measured by the week and by the month.
It'll be every Sabbath and every new
moon that we will come to worship before
the Lord. The Sabbath is once a week,
the seventh day event, a seventh day
event. And the new moon is once a month.
It's a once a month event. Now,
Revelation chapter 22:2 is another verse
we want to look at that uses the month
to describe how often we partake of the
tree of life that yields her fruit for
the nations. In Revelation chapter 22
and:e 2 it says in the midst of the
street of it and on either side of the
river was there the tree of life which
beare 12 manner of fruits and yielded
her fruit every month and the leaves of
the tree were for the healing of the
nations. So from these Bible texts we
have the weekly cycle and the monthly
cycle of time in heaven. So, Revelation
21:23 indicates that day and night will
not be a time measurement any longer
when we get to heaven. Notice what it
says there. And the city had no need of
the sun, neither of the moon to shine in
it, for the glory of God did lighten it,
and the lamb is the light thereof. In
fact, Isaiah 40 and:31 kind of confirms
this idea as it indicates that we won't
grow weary or tired and need to sleep in
the new heaven and the new earth. Notice
what it says here in Isaiah
40:31. But they that wait upon the Lord
shall renew their strength. They shall
mount up with wings as eagles. They
shall run and not be weary. They shall
walk and not faint. Oh, that's going to
be a glorious day. As I get older,
walking and running definitely bring
faintness. But there's a day coming when
our energy will be renewed day and
night. No more measuring time by 8 to
fives or 410s. I can't wait for the
weekends or vacation or holidays or
retirements. In heaven, we measure time
by the Sabbath and by which is a time to
rejoice and worship God. A holy get
together, we should say, singing and
praising God with glorious uh his
glorious awesome name. Or we measure
time by the month, the time we partake
again of the tree of life, which
perpetuates the immortality that is
given to us at the resurrection. So I
hope this is helpful in answering your
questions, thirsten.
Beautiful. We know in 1 Corinthians 2:9,
eyes have not seen,
your ears have not heard what the Lord
has for us. We can't even imagine when
we get to heaven, we're just going to be
like, wow. and those who slept, those
saints that have died and family who
love the Lord, we will be reunited
again. So, I'm looking forward to that
and meeting all the Bible writers. This
is going to be a beautiful place that I
am looking forward to and I hope you are
too. Thank you for that. All right,
Pastor
Maronei, can you explain the meaning of
Genesis 9 verse 22?
What does it mean that Ham uncovered his
father's nakedness? This is from
Fernando in
Massachusetts. Well, I learned from this
one, too, Fernando. So, thank you for
sending this question in. Let me read
the story here in Genesis 9 for our
viewers. Verse 21 says, "And he drank of
the wine and was drunken, and he was
uncovered within his tent. And Ham the
father of Canaan saw the nakedness of
his father and told his two brethren
without. And Shem and Japheth took a
garment, laid it upon both of their
shoulders, and went backward and covered
the nakedness of their father, and their
faces were backward, and they saw not
their father's nakedness.
So it sounds like Ham, he went in, you
know, he saw his father laying there.
he'd been drinking. So, had been a
little time after the flood was done,
you know, had gotten some vineyards
going, some grapes going. So, um Ham
instead of covering his father so that
he couldn't he wouldn't be ashamed when
he woke up, they might have had some
grandchildren running around and so
forth that would have this indecent
exposure and that would have embarrassed
him. He actually ran outside or walked
outside and told his brothers possibly
in a contemptuous way or even making fun
of his father. We have the meaning of
being uncovered here uncovering his
father's nakedness in Leviticus 18 6 and
7. It's this, you know, Moses wrote
Genesis and then he's writing Leviticus
here. It says, "None of you shall
approach to any that is near of kin to
him to uncover their nakedness. I am the
Lord. The nakedness of thy father or the
nakedness of thy mother shalt thou not
uncover. She is thy mother. Thou shalt
not uncover her nakedness. So the Hebrew
word for uncover is gala and it can have
several meanings. It can mean denude,
especially in a disgraceful sense. It
can mean disclose or discover or reveal
or
publish to show or expose shamelessly.
Those are all meanings that could have
been translated in our English. So it
sounds like what Ham did after he saw
his his dad naked and went and told his
brothers, you could say that he
published his father's shame or
nakedness. Again, possibly, you know,
don't know for sure, making fun of his
father's shame, but exposing him rather
than protecting him. And there was a lot
of reverence for parents and elders. You
know, we might not think of it's a big
deal today, but there was sacredness,
you know, almost like representing God,
you know, their parents and their
elders. All right. Well, thank you again
for that question. Hope that helped.
Amen. A lot of respect for the parents.
That's right. I said, "Yeah, thank you
so much for that." Okay, honey. Pastor
Lom Kang, here we go. If you are a
Seventh Day Adventist, is it wrong to
attend church on Sunday if you miss
Sabbath services? This is from Nora in
Utah. Well, it depends on the motive.
And I think this is a question that this
is such an individual answer that uh the
way that it came across was if they miss
Sabbath service, will they also attend
church on Sunday? And what's wrong with
that? Now this once again kind of goes
along with my earlier question because
what happens is John 4:23 the issue here
is worship. The issue is not attending
and not going to a building. We don't go
to church just because it has great
music or wonderful action or we like the
atmosphere or we like the services. The
the purpose for the church from the book
of Exodus the Lord said to Pharaoh, "Let
my people go that they may worship me."
You find also throughout the New
Testament, the New Testament church was
established for the purpose of worship.
If we go to church for any other reason
other than worship, our motives are not
pure. Now, if we're just going for
fellowship, you can have fellowship with
one another, but that fellowship must
always be on the basis of worship. The
word quania is a worship that is for the
purpose of honoring God. In Revelation
14, its message is uh fear God and give
glory to him for the hour is judgment
has come and worship him that made
heaven and earth, the sea and the
fountains of waters. So, it's all about
worship. And then John 4:23 and 24, but
the hour is coming and now is when the
true worshipper will worship the father
in spirit and in truth. For the father
is seeking such to worship him. God is
spirit and those who worship him must
worship in spirit and truth. Let me put
context to this.
There are some individuals that are
musicians and they say, "Well, uh, the
Methodist church or the Pentecostal
church or this other denomination hired
me to play because they have no
organist." That's one thing. But if you
say, "You know what? I missed church
yesterday on Sabbath. I'm going to go to
church on Sunday." Once again, that goes
down to being caught between two gods
because you're saying, "Well, this day
is just as good as that one. I miss one,
I go to the other." That's not
scriptural. That is not supported by the
Bible. The substituting of the Sabbath
by Sunday is a tradition and we've got
to acknowledge that. Too many people
say, "Well, it really doesn't matter."
Well, if it didn't matter to God, he
wouldn't say in Exodus 20:10, "The
seventh day is the Sabbath of the Lord
your God." The question really is not
what day you go to church on. The
question is, who is your God? And when
you answer that question, it's clearly
accepted and established as to what day
God blessed to honor him and to worship
him. Now, if you go because your friend
says, "Hey, I went to your church. You
come with me." That's a different story
altogether. That's a quantineia. They're
saying, "I I I need your support."
That's a different thing. But I said
this and I want to say this again. One
of the reasons why the Hebrews never
bowed on the plane of Dura, and this is
powerful. Oh yeah. When the music was
played, the reason why the Hebrews never
bowed is because when
worship demands that you bow at the
wrong altar, it ceases to be worship to
the true God. That's why they did not
bow at the Babylonian altar. Elijah said
to the people, "How long do you falter
between two opinions? If the Lord is
God, follow him. But if Baal, follow
him." And what happened? The people did
not answer a word. Why? because he was
stuck between two polarities. Make a
decision that your worship is to the
true God and make sure that your motives
are in line with that. Amen. Amen. I
love that. And it's it's the God, right?
It's all about what you worship. The
true God. Yeah. It's not about the day
of worship. It's about the true God.
He'll give you the day that he
established. He will give you. Yes. He's
already established it. Amen. And it's
already established from the in the ten
commandments from day one. And Jesus
said the Sabbath was made for man. Yes.
Mark 2 verse 28. Yes. 27 and 28. Yes.
And Pastor Rafidy, I have a quick
question for you. When because you were
not raised a seventh day Adventist, was
the Sabbath difficult for you to
accept when you came in to this church?
It was at first. In fact, I told my si
my sister told me about the Sabbath. You
know, she said, "You should be going to
church on Saturday." And I said, "That's
ridiculous." And I said, 'The Bible
doesn't teach that. I knew nothing of
the Bible except the Lord's prayer. I
was raised Catholic at that time. And
but I figured that if two mill billion
people, two billion people uh keep the
Sabbath, I mean keep Sunday a Sabbath,
then Sunday must be the day in the
Bible. So it was very difficult at
first, but once I started to study the
word of God and I learned from the word
of God that the seventh day was the
Sabbath, it was very easy. And I'll tell
you why. Because when I accepted Jesus
Christ as my savior, my personal savior
without knowing anything about
Adventists, I I fell in love with Jesus,
he had forgiven me. He had lifted my the
guilt off my shoulders. He had changed
my life. And you know, Jesus says, if
you love me, keep my commandments. And I
remember thinking when I was convicted
on the Sabbath of that verse, if you
love me, I do love Jesus, keep my
commandments. I said, that's the least I
can do. So, it was hard at first, but it
became very easy after I was convicted
that the Sabbath was the seventh day.
Amen. Amen. It's a love relationship,
isn't it? Your love to God. And so, that
became easy once you learned you, you
know, you know who God is and you love
him. So, keeping the Sabbath was no
problem, right? That's right. Right.
Yeah. How long after? Just like going to
church on Sunday was no problem because
I thought Sunday was the day and I loved
Jesus and I go to church on Sunday. As
soon as I realized, whoops, I got the
wrong day. The motive was still the
same. Love, but I just corrected to the
day the Bible actually teaches. Yeah.
Wow. Yeah. You know, we live in a
duplicitous environment today where
after the Protestant Reformation, so
many different movements spring up. But
the Lord is calling his people back. The
key is he said, "Other sheep I have that
are not of this fold." But he doesn't
stop there. He said, "Them also I must
bring and they will hear my voice." Yes.
And they'll be one fold and one
shepherd. So the Advent message is a
gathering message. Yes. Yes. Calling
people back to the fold that the Lord
established. And that is those who keep
the commandments of God and have the
testimony of Jesus Christ. And what does
the Bible say? Come out of her. Come out
of her, my people. And God's people are
out there and you will hear the voice of
God telling you to come out and join the
remnant. So God bless you. What we're
going to do is take a short break and
hear from our panelists. We'll be right
back.
If you're enjoying our 3AN Bible Q&A,
then tell your friends. Each Monday,
we'll bring you a fresh program
answering the Bible questions you send
us using God's holy word to shed light
on those texts that seem difficult to
understand. To have your questions
answered on a future program, just email
them to us at
bibleqa3abn.tv. That's
bibleqa3abn.tv. You may also text your
questions to 6182283975.
That's
618-228-3975. Be sure to include your
name and where you live and then watch
through a Bible Q&A for answers from
God's word.
Welcome back. We have a few closing
thoughts from our pastors and we're
going to start with Pastor Daniel.
Pastor Daniel Maronei, I just want to
clarify the my answer to Lee here where
he asked about those people that are
have never heard the gospel if they
could be saved. I just want to clarify
that we aren't saved by our works at
all. No, it's the Holy Spirit working in
our hearts, pointing us to Jesus, and we
accept Jesus by faith. That's how we are
saved. Thank you. Amen. Pastor Oh,
Pastor James. Yeah, I love that because
because the works are the fruit of our
salvation. So people who do respond to
Jesus will have good works in their
lives. Just another clarification on
question number one. The symbolism that
we find of the bride being the new
Jerusalem and the bride also being God's
people. You know a day in Bible prophecy
is symbolic of 24 of a year. But it's
also can represent 24 hours or part of
24 hours. It can also be symbolic of a
thousand years even in indefinite time.
We talk about the day of the Lord. So we
have to allow the Bible to interpret the
symbol but also for the symbol to fit
the context of what we're studying.
Amen. That's right, Pastor John. Very
simply, when we talk about uh worship,
there were two questions that had to do
with worship and Sunday and whether or
not it matters. You know, the motives of
the heart is something that only God can
judge. We want to make sure that we
understand that and we communicate that
as a people. And as a pastor, I can't
say, "Well, you go here and you go
there, well, therefore you're saved and
you're lost." That's going to be decided
by the Lord. But make sure that your
pursuit is righteousness and serving God
according to the spirit and truth as his
word reveals. Amen. Thank you so much
for joining us. Thank you, Pastor Rapid.
Thank you, Pastor Maronei. And thank
you, Pastor Lang. I hope you were
blessed. I was blessed. Remember the
word of God. Study it to show yourself
approved unto him. and have a blessed
day in Jesus.
[Music]
Amen.
Heat. Heat.
[Music]
Heat.